revisamos nuestra salud del día de hoy
hablamos de salud con más romeros al mar
seguimos hablando de la emergencia
climática no nuestro tema del día esta
vez sobre los efectos que tendrá ese
calentamiento global sobre nosotros que
podemos esperar hay que preocuparnos más
si definitivamente si hay que
preocuparnos no me gustaría venir solo a
dar malas noticias pero es que se
avecina la mayor crisis de salud pública
que tendremos en el futuro incluso mayor
que la pandemia de kobe 19
definitivamente el cambio climático va a
cambiar en nuestra vida y también va a
cambiar como nos enfermamos y como nos
morimos también de que enfermedades
morimos la organización mundial de la
salud calcula que son 250.000 las
muertes anuales que podría provocar el
cambio climático a partir de 2030 entre
2030 y 2050 porque porque habrán
enfermedades que aumentan como por
ejemplo el paludismo enfermedades
diarreicas como el cólera también por
las olas de calor que ya vimos cómo
afectaban también en el hemisferio norte
durante el verano de los últimos meses y
también al final la principal causa la
desnutrición son 95 mil muertes anuales
que podrían ocurrir de desnutrición
infantil al final sí no como
alimentarnos si no tenemos acceso al
agua todo el resto no hay no hay nada
que valga eso agravar cualquier otro
tipo de enfermedad y definitivamente no
es va a enfermar pues no poder comer no
poder beber tenemos que estar muy
pendientes de que pase con eso y la
buena suerte es que al menos estamos a
tiempo de cambiar de rumbo a tiempo y
ojalá no usemos esa máscara que tenía
usted en ese gráfico una máscara toda
cerrada para poder respirar ojalá no la
tengamos que usar nunca marca
enfermedades vamos a ver que aumentan
con ese cambio climático pues
básicamente son varias estábamos
adelantando algunas de ellas
enfermedades transmisibles por ejemplo
como en la malaria como el dengue que se
van a expandir a otras regiones se lo
preguntamos al doctor elvis garcía
doctor en salud pública por la
universidad de harvard y esto fue lo que
nos dijo
se prevé que con el cambio climático
enfermedades como la malaria y el dengue
se expandirán a otras partes del mundo y
esto implica cientos de millones de
infecciones al año y con ello miles de
muertes son enfermedades que afectan en
su mayoría países en desarrollo y por
eso no hay no ha habido históricamente
demasiado investigación desarrollo para
este tipo de enfermedades pero veremos
que hay cada vez más interés cuando
estas enfermedades empiezan a llegar a
países a países ricos como al llegar a
esta enfermedad a los países que decimos
ricos o al norte global pues básicamente
porque el caliente calentamiento global
va a favorecer la expansión
del vector de esta enfermedad de lo que
transmite este tipo de enfermedades en
este caso los mosquitos para el dengue o
para la malaria es un efecto que se verá
a medio plazo pero definitivamente
tenemos que estar preparados y quizás
ahí es donde las desigualdades también
en la investigación en la salud voy a
hacer un tiro que salga por la culata
para los países ricos no enfermedades
que nunca les hemos prestado mucha
atención y que nos van a terminar
afectando que otras enfermedades también
enfermedades transmisibles como el
cólera se transmite a través de una
bacteria que también él de humedad del
aumento de lluvias del aumento de
temperatura podría facilitar su aumento
de transmisión y que llegue a regiones
sobre todo donde la gente no está
preparada no conoce los efectos de esta
enfermedad y eso haría que pues todavía
aumente más la crisis de salud pública
que se puede prever raúl la verdad es
que como ves son unos escenarios un poco
preocupantes preocupantes y mucho más
pero además del aumento las temperaturas
también sabemos que la contaminación nos
afecta a nosotros si de hecho ya que
hablabas de las máscaras es pero no
tenemos que usarlas pero pues más vale
empezar a prepararnos porque todo apunta
así y ya al menos la pandemia nos
algunos acostumbra al tapabocas en qué
tipo de enfermedades podemos ver que
aumenten por culpa de las
contaminaciones atmosféricas las
enfermedades por ejemplo pulmonares las
enfermedades cardiovasculares no hace
falta que vayamos mucho al futuro para
ver esto ya está pasando en el momento
actual siete millones de personas
pierden la vida a causa de la
contaminación y de la polución
atmosféricos es una muerte cada 13
minutos según cifras de la organización
mundial de la que también apunta que el
90 por ciento de la población del mundo
vive en zonas donde la contaminación del
aire aún es superior a los niveles
recomendados qué tipo de
dolencias provocan estas enfermedades
básicamente pues que los pulmones se
envejezcan de manera acelerada
asma cáncer de pulmón también pero no
sólo al final en el sistema respiratorio
sino también en el sistema circulatorio
en el cerebro podemos ver aumentos de
infartos aumentos de derrames el doctor
elvis garcía también fue quien nos dijo
algunos apuntes de cómo tenemos que
preocuparnos
pensamos directamente en el efecto de la
polución y enfermedades pulmonares que
está ahí que hay mucha literatura que lo
demuestra pero no podemos quedarnos en
eso hay por ejemplo también estudios que
han demostrado como la exposición a la
contaminación impacta también por
ejemplo en el desarrollo de el
desarrollo cerebral de los niños así que
es mucho más importante de lo que de lo
que creemos marc y es que además los
desastres naturales también nos van a
afectar más
los más directos que hay al final sobre
nuestra salud más allá de las heridas de
los traumas que pueda provocar estar en
un momento de desastre natural también
va a tener un efecto grave sobre la
infraestructura sanitaria cifras de la
organización panamericana de la salud
apuntan que el 67 por ciento de la
infraestructura hospitalaria de los
centros sanitarios del continente
americano está en zonas de riesgo eso
significa que no habrá infraestructura
para atender los problemas de salud que
ocurran no es un problema que de hecho
ya está en el presente como ven en este
gráfico también son 24 millones de
personas las que se quedaron sin
atención hospitalaria debido a una
problema de un desastre natural esto fue
entre la década de 2010 y 2020 por lo
tanto pues si no la infraestructura
preparada para responder a esta
emergencia que se nos viene encima raúl
no tenemos nada que hacer si no hay
hospitales si no hay médicos que nos
atiendan todo esto se va a grabar con
unas magnitudes que yo creo que no nos
podemos imaginar bien dimar y no nos
vayamos tan lejos y ya ayer hablamos
precisamente de haití país que fue
sacudido por terremotos y todavía sufre
estas consecuencias
es su infraestructura hospitalaria
completamente dañada
bueno el lunes espero que tenga mejores
noticias es nuestra sección les
enfrentaremos lo prometo feliz fin de
semana nosotros vamos con nuestro
segundo invitado el día